Peter has been on the job for 20 years. He's got the uniform. He's got the office in the basement behind the laundry room. He's got the keys.
彼得已经在这份工作上干了20年了。他有制服，在洗衣房后面的地下室里有办公室，还有钥匙。
[JINGLING KEYS]
[钥匙叮当声]
That's a lot of crap on there, but hey.
上面的玩意儿挺多的，不过嘛。
Let's just count them.
我们来数数看吧。
Let's basically count them.
基本上就是数一数。
Yeah.
没错。
All right, so you got your 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
好了，你这里有1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8、9、10、11。
This is a keyring that is so big that it not only has tons of keys, it also has smaller baby key rings-- subsidiary key rings hanging off of it, each with its own keys. And almost none of these keys has any kind of label indicating what it is that it opens. And have you ever seen a guy carrying this kind of thing, and you've wondered, OK, well, how does he remember which key goes to which lock? Oh, wait a second. Peter's nearly done counting.
这串钥匙实在太大，不仅有很多钥匙，上面还挂着更小的婴儿钥匙圈——附属钥匙圈，每个上面都有自己的钥匙。几乎没有一把钥匙贴有标签说明它到底开的是什么。你有没有见过一个家伙带着这种东西，然后纳闷，好吧，他是怎么记得哪把钥匙开哪把锁的呢？哦，等一下，彼得快数完了。
45, 46, 47, 48, 49. It's about 50 keys.
45、46、47、48、49。大约有50把钥匙。
He actually skipped a lot of keys. Anyway, I was saying, if you ever wondered how he remembers which key goes to which thing, Peter says 3/4 of these keys, he has no idea what they're for.
他实际上跳过了很多钥匙。总之，我刚才在说，如果你曾经好奇他是怎么记得哪把钥匙开哪个东西的，彼得说这其中3/4的钥匙，他根本不知道是干什么用的。
Every time I change a lock or I get a new key to this or that, it just gets added on there. I never took the time to take the old ones off.
每次我换锁或者得到一把新钥匙，它就直接加到上面去了。我从来没花时间把旧的取下来。
Practical. Above all, Peter is a practical man. In his line of work, that's essential. He's a super, in charge of keeping the elevators humming, and the boiler going, and the roof from leaking, and the sidewalks clean, and 100 other things every single day. He works at a fancy building on New York's Upper East Side.
实用。最重要的是，彼得是个务实的人。在他的工作岗位上，这至关重要。他是一位大楼管理员，负责让电梯嗡嗡作响，让锅炉运转，让屋顶不漏水，让街道干净，还有每天其他100件事。他在纽约上东区的一栋高级大楼工作。
Or maybe I should say it's a medium-fancy building, fancy enough that Woody Allen and Mayor Giuliani shopped for apartments there, but not fancy enough that they actually moved in. To hold a job like this for very long, even in a medium-fancy building, you have to sweat the details of everything.
或者我应该说那是一栋中等高级的大楼，高级到伍迪·艾伦和朱利安尼市长都在那儿看中过公寓，但还没高级到他们真的搬进去。要在这样一份工作中长久待下去，即使是在一栋中等高级的大楼里，你也必须对每一处细节都费尽心思。
My compactor room, a woman could give birth, no infection would set in. Come, I'll show you.
我的垃圾压缩机房，女人在那儿生孩子都不会感染。来，我带你去看看。
He uses a key from the part of the key chain where he knows what's going on. And suddenly we're in an immaculate room with concrete floors.
他从钥匙链上他知道用途的那部分拿出一把钥匙。突然间，我们进了一个有水泥地面的干净房间。
Oh my god, it's so wonderful in here. [INHALES] And this is the garbage room.
天哪，这儿太棒了。[吸气]这就是垃圾房。
It doesn't smell like garbage.
闻起来一点也不像垃圾。
No. You want to go up to the roof and oil the circulation pumps with me?
不。你想跟我去屋顶给循环泵上油吗？
That really has to be the worst pickup line ever. We dropped by the pump room to check some gauges, and then we head back into the elevator and pass one of the doormen who works with Peter.
那绝对是史上最烂的搭讪语。我们顺道去了水泵房检查了一些仪表，然后回到电梯，经过了和彼得一起工作的一位门卫。
Martin, your parole officer called. Give him a call.
马丁，你的假释官打来电话。回他个电话吧。
Martin smiles. The doors close.
马丁笑了笑。电梯门关上了。
So can you joke around with the tenants in this building?
那你在这栋楼里能跟住户开玩笑吗？
Not like that. No, you don't want to go there. I'm pretty friendly with some of them, but there's a line. Yeah. I tell these guys, you've got to keep it short and sweet. Good morning. Good evening. How about them Knicks? Happy holidays.
不能那样。不，你别那样做。我和其中一些人还挺熟的，但有一条界限。是的。我告诉这些家伙，必须简短客气。早上好。晚上好。尼克斯队表现怎么样？节日快乐。
Martin's kind of new. He wanted to say Happy Hanukkah to a few people. I said, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. No Merry Christmas, no Happy Hanukkah. It's happy holidays. Oh, but, uh-- I said, no. You're going to miss. You're going to miss. I'm telling you, you're going to miss. You're going to throw one the wrong way, and it's going to come back.
马丁算是新人。他想跟几个人说光明节快乐。我说，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。别说圣诞快乐，也别说光明节快乐。就说节日快乐。哦，但是，呃——我说，不。你会说错的。你会弄巧成拙的。我告诉你，你会出错的。你会搞砸的，到时候又要补救。
It's delicate, dealing with the tenants-- surprisingly delicate. People in the building gossip about him. Then he's got his own secret thoughts about them, too.
跟住户打交道是很微妙的——出奇地微妙。楼里的人会对他议论纷纷。然后他自己对他们也有一些秘密想法。
For today in our program, we have stories of the super. He sees everybody come and go. He knows way more about the tenants than they know about him. I mean, Peter has a security camera, for God's sake. He's on call 24 hours a day. He's both a figure of authority and kind of an in-house servant.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于管理员的故事。他看着每个人来来去去。他了解住户的程度远超他们对他的了解。我是说，看在上帝的份上，彼得甚至还有监控摄像头。他24小时待命。他既是一个权威人物，又像是一个内部仆人。
From WBEZ Chicago is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in three acts-- three very dramatic acts, actually, starting-- let's just get right to it-- starting with this one from Jack Hitt. His act is like an epic novel with plot twists, and unforeseen danger, and bizarre coincidences, and unlikely heroes, and even more unlikely bad guys. Here's Jack.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为三幕——实际上是非常戏剧性的三幕，从——我们直接切入正题——从杰克·希特讲述的这一幕开始。他的叙述就像一部情节曲折、危险重重、充满了离奇巧合、意想不到的英雄，甚至还有更出人意料的坏人的史诗小说。有请杰克。
During New York City's great crime wave of the 1980s, getting an apartment was simple. All you had to do was commit a crime.
在纽约市80年代那场巨大的犯罪浪潮中，找公寓很简单。你要做的仅仅是犯个罪。
We had heard from a friend of a friend that if we went down and gave key money-- that is to say, one month's rent, it was the going fee-- to this superintendent-- that is to say, Bob-- that we would be able to get an apartment.
我们从朋友的朋友那里听说，如果我们去付点“钥匙费”——也就是一个月租金，那是当时的行规——给这个管理员——也就是鲍勃——我们就能弄到一套公寓。
This is my friend Kevin. He and I got our apartments in the same building on 99th Street in the early '80s by bribing the same superintendent, a guy named Bob. These were old beat-up flats with screaming radiators and warped floors and exposed pipes. A city engineer once inspected the building and declared that it was six stories of dust, held up by 100 years of paint.
这是我的朋友凯文。80年代初，我和他在99街的同一栋楼里，通过贿赂同一个叫鲍勃的管理员拿到了各自的公寓。那些都是破破烂烂的旧公寓，暖气片尖叫，地板变形，管道外露。一位城市工程师曾检查过这栋楼，宣称这是由100年的油漆支撑着的6层尘埃。
These were our first New York apartments. We were there to start our lives. New York was all romance, and everything was outsized and outrageous-- the buildings in Midtown, our ambition, the nightlife, and as we quickly discovered, our super, Bob. All sorts of things about him were truly spectacular, like, for example, the way he repaired our apartments. Here's Chris, another tenant in the building.
这些是我们最初的纽约公寓。我们在那里开启自己的生活。纽约全是浪漫，一切都庞大且离谱——中城的建筑、我们的抱负、夜生活，还有我们很快就发现的，我们的管理员鲍勃。关于他的各种事情都真正地引人入胜，比如，他修理我们公寓的方式。这是克里斯，楼里的另一位住户。
After we got burglarized, Bob put in safety gates for the fire escape, which he welded so that nobody could get in, but you couldn't get out in a fire either. There was no way to open them.
我们被入室盗窃后，鲍勃装了防火梯的安全门，他把它焊死了，这样没人能进来，但在火灾中你也出不去。根本没法打开。
He told us that they were installing sliding revolving doors, which he never explained what those were, but I do remember thinking to myself, how can he say they're sliding revolving doors? But he said it with such a totally straight face.
他告诉我们他们正在安装滑动旋转门，他从来没解释过那是什么，但我记得我当时心想，他怎么能说那是滑动旋转门呢？但他面不改色地说出了这些话。
Bob's work habits were a thing of wonder. I remember one time, Bob showed up with his assistant, a generally talented guy named Smitty. My sink was backed up, and Bob started pouring this heavy black liquid from a gallon jug into the standing water. Smitty started backing up, and with experience as my guide, I started backing up, too. "One cup," Smitty yelled, "just one cup." "Shut up," Bob explained.
鲍勃的工作习惯简直令人称奇。我记得有一次，鲍勃带着他的助手，一个通常很有天赋的家伙叫史密蒂过来。我的水槽堵了，鲍勃开始把一种浓稠的黑色液体从加仑桶里倒进积水里。史密蒂开始后退，凭着经验，我也开始后退。“一杯，”史密蒂喊道，“只要一杯。”“闭嘴，”鲍勃解释说。
And he emptied the entire jug into the water. There were nasty rumblings. Hot chemical reactions were happening somewhere in the walls. I was very scared. And suddenly the doors below the sink where I kept my cleaning stuff, they blew open with an explosion. And this unspeakable oily sludge poured out across the kitchen floor. Bob was so much more than just a bad handyman.
然后他把整桶都倒进了水里。传来一阵恶心的隆隆声。某种化学反应正在墙壁里发生。我非常害怕。突然，我存放清洁用品的水槽下方的门被炸开了。一股难以名状的油腻污泥涌到了厨房地板上。鲍勃不仅仅是一个糟糕的杂工，他简直是个传奇。
Very early on, I began to perceive Bob's talents as a fabulist. It was really painful to go down and pay the rent every month. You had to give it to him, which meant you had to stand there and listen to 10, 15, 20 minutes of completely insane stories. A big running theme was Bob's importance in the world in general, and particularly in Brazil.
很早开始，我就开始察觉到鲍勃作为一个编造故事者的天赋。每月下楼去交房租简直是种痛苦。你得把它交给他，这意味着你得站在那儿，听他讲10分钟、15分钟、20分钟完全疯癫的故事。一个大的主旋律是鲍勃在世界上，特别是在巴西的崇高地位。
I definitely remember his cattle ranch stories.
我绝对记得他关于养牛场的故事。
This is Anne, another tenant during those early days, and now married to Chris.
这是安妮，那些早年间的另一位住户，现在嫁给了克里斯。
He had seven cattle ranches, four cattle ranches he owned in Brazil, and the seven vineyards he had in Italy. Or it might have been seven cattle ranches in Brazil and four vineyards in Italy.
他在巴西有七个养牛场，四个养牛场是他拥有的，还有他在意大利的七个葡萄园。或者可能是七个养牛场四个葡萄园。
If you actually took him-- after he left the room and you thought about what he said, you'd think, why is he living here? Because he was like basically a king. The village people would just welcome him.
如果你真的带他——在他离开房间后，你仔细琢磨他说的话，你会想，他为什么住在这里？因为他基本上就像个国王。村民们见到他都会欢迎他。
He claimed that there was a clause in the constitution of Brazil that gave him immunity from any prosecution whatsoever. And that, in fact, he could, as he put it, go and kill the president of the Brazilian state, and he would still be immune from prosecution.
他声称巴西宪法中有一条条款赋予他免受任何起诉的豁免权。事实上，正如他所说，他甚至可以去杀了巴西总统，依然能够免受起诉。
Of course, Bob, being Bob, had an explanation for how he went from being a South American cattle baron to a New York City super.
当然，鲍勃不愧是鲍勃，对于他如何从南美养牛大亨变成纽约市管理员，他也有解释。
He had had two heart attacks, and his doctor had-- this is an actual story. His doctor had prescribed that he gain a lot of weight and move to America. So probably the first time in medical history that enormous weight gain was prescribed for a heart condition.
他得了两次心脏病，医生——这是一个真实的故事——医生给他开了处方，让他大量增重并搬到美国。这可能是医学史上第一次为心脏病开出的处方居然是大幅度增重。
In his own way, Bob united the building. All of us, the elderly black businessman, the Puerto Rican grandmother, the handsome Bombay immigrant, me, the Southerner in exile, we all had our favorite Bob stories. We all did our own impersonations of Bob. It was impossible not to try to out-Bob whoever was talking with an even more outlandish Bob story of your own. We collected and traded Bob stories, comparing versions, analyzing his technique.
以他自己的方式，鲍勃凝聚了这栋大楼。我们所有人，年长的黑人商人、波多黎各老祖母、英俊的孟买移民、我这个流亡的南方人，我们都有自己最喜欢的鲍勃故事。我们都模仿过鲍勃。如果不试图讲一个比说话的人更离谱的鲍勃故事来超越对方，那是不可能的。我们收集并交换鲍勃故事，比较不同版本，分析他的技巧。
He was remarkably unfazed by any show of skepticism about his stories. There was the story about how he had once hung a bag of acid from the roof of the building to chase away the various homeless men who would, in those days, often come and congregate by the edge-- the corner of this building. Bob had supposedly hung a bag of acid from the top that would drip down steadily on them.
对于任何对他故事的怀疑，他都表现得泰然自若。有个故事说，他曾经从楼顶挂下一袋酸液，去驱赶那些在那段时期经常在楼角聚集的无家可归者。鲍勃据说从上面挂了一袋酸液，会稳定地滴在他们身上。
Now I have no idea how you hang a bag of acid-- how you get the acid in the bag and put that up there. That's no small feat in itself. But of course, the best part is Bob is telling us this story at the very same time that you could lean out of the office where he's talking and see the three or four homeless guys sitting on the corner--
现在我不知道你怎么能挂起一袋酸液——你怎么把酸液装进袋子里并把它弄上去。这本身就不是件小事。但当然，最好的部分是，鲍勃在跟我们讲这个故事的同时，你可以从他说话的办公室向外探身，看到那三四个无家可归的家伙正坐在墙角——
Sitting right there.
正坐在那儿。
--apparently completely unscarred or bothered by dripping acid.
——看起来完全没有被滴下的酸液伤害或困扰。
The other story that I've always found really captured just sort of like all of Bob's essence for me was when-- every kitchen in this building has these funny, circular fluorescent bulbs, very specialized light bulbs. They're also in the hallways out on the first floor.
另一个我一直觉得最能体现鲍勃精髓的故事是——这栋楼里每个厨房都有那种有趣的圆形荧光灯泡，非常特殊的灯泡。一楼走廊里也有。
And mine, after 10 years of noble service, finally burnt out. And I looked at it, and I thought, huh. Where do you buy one of those? So I trotted on down to Bob's office one morning, and I said, Bob, the light bulb in my kitchen has burned out. And I'm just wondering, do I buy that and replace it? And if so, where do you buy them? Or do you all just replace that for me?
我的那个在辛勤工作了10年后终于烧坏了。我看着它，想，哈，去哪里买那种东西呢？于是有一天早上我溜到鲍勃办公室，我说，鲍勃，我厨房里的灯泡坏了。我在想，是我自己买来换吗？如果是的话，去哪儿买？还是你们帮我换？
And of course, he went into this total Bob tear. He was like, yes, that's right. You, let me tell you something, mister. Don't try to steal one of the light bulbs in the hallway. I know what you're thinking. But I've booby trapped them. And if you climb up there and you try to take the light bulb, it will blow up and shoot the glass in your eyes. And you will be blind for all time.
当然，他又开始了那套鲍勃式的表演。他说，没错，就是这样。小伙子，我告诉你件事。别想偷走走廊里的灯泡。我知道你在想什么。但我已经设了陷阱。如果你爬上去试图拿走灯泡，它就会爆炸，把玻璃射进你的眼睛。你会永远失明。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I said-- I remember saying, so I take that to mean that I have to buy the bulb myself.
然后我说——我记得我当时说，所以我理解成我得自己买那个灯泡了。
The very opposite of Bob was Allan, the landlord. If Bob was larger than life, Allan was smack in the middle, the average percentile. He had a family. He lived in White Plains. I had met his wife. Doing business with Allan was a completely routine experience. If it was a toilet to be fixed, he'd make sure the crew got there on time and got it done. Even in our biggest blowouts, he was always reasonable, civil even.
房东艾伦与鲍勃截然相反。如果说鲍勃是超乎寻常的，那艾伦就是中规中矩，平平无奇。他有家庭，住在怀特普莱恩斯。我见过他妻子。和艾伦做生意是完全例行的公事。如果马桶要修，他会确保修理队按时赶到并修好。即使在我们最激烈的冲突中，他也总是讲理，甚至很有礼貌。
One time, things got a little testy when Allan started neglecting the old Puerto Rican folks in the building. I'd become friendly with one grandmother, who showed me her tub full of green stagnant bathwater. Allan and I had some tense words, and I and some others even held meetings to start a rent strike. But in the end, Allan gracefully withdrew, and we all went back to normal business. Back to Bob-- the inscrutable, endless mystery that was Bob.
有一次，当艾伦开始忽视楼里那群波多黎各老人时，事情变得有点紧张。我和一位祖母变得很熟，她给我看了她浴缸里满满一盆绿色的死水。艾伦和我发生了一些激烈的争执，我和其他人甚至还开了会准备发动租金罢工。但最终，艾伦优雅地退让了，我们也都恢复了正常的业务。回到鲍勃——那个深不可测、无尽谜团的鲍勃身上。
Fast forward to 1989. I'd been in my apartment eight years. I had a steady job, and I was walking to work one morning. Somewhere along the way, I saw The Daily News blaring the latest tabloid crime story. Headline, "Terror Landlord." I looked closer and realized it was Allan-- my Allan, the landlord, the nice guy whose kids I knew.
时间跳到1989年。我在那套公寓住了八年。我有了一份稳定的工作，一天早上正走去上班。路上，我看到《每日新闻》刊登了最新的小报犯罪故事。头条是“恐怖房东”。我仔细看了一下，意识到那是艾伦——我的艾伦，那个房东，那个我认识他孩子的不错的人。
The story was incredible. He had been arrested for murder for hiring hitmen to kill his brother-in-law, Arthur Katz, in 1980. And as the story got out, it quickly became clear that Bob was the one who had ratted Allan out. Allan was found guilty and sentenced to 25 years to life in prison, where he remains today.
这个故事令人难以置信。他因谋杀罪被捕，因为他在1980年雇佣杀手杀害了他的姐夫亚瑟·卡茨。随着故事的曝光，很快就很清楚，是鲍勃举报了艾伦。艾伦被判有罪，入狱25年至终身监禁，直到今天他还被关在里面。
More time passed. I got a new apartment in the West Village. Then I got married, had children, and later moved to another state, where Allan and Bob became memories, proof that I lived in New York back when crack was king and the murder rates topped 2,000 a year. In the late '90s, almost a decade after I'd last seen Bob or Allan, I was working on an investigative piece about money laundering, and a source at the Treasury Department had suggested I call this really smart prosecutor in New York named John Moscow.
更多的时间过去了。我在西村弄到了新公寓。后来我结婚、有了孩子，之后搬到了另一个州，在那里，艾伦和鲍勃成了记忆，证明我在可卡因横行、谋杀率每年超过2000起的年代住过纽约。90年代末，距离我上次见到鲍勃或艾伦已近十年，我正在做一个关于洗钱的调查报道，财政部的一位消息来源建议我打电话给纽约一位非常聪明的检察官，名叫约翰·莫斯科。
So I rang him up and started just yakking, the, way you do. I asked him if he'd handled financial crime a lot, and he was quick to say that he'd worked homicide in New York back in the '80s, during the crime wave, when crack was king and the murder rates topped 2,000 a year. Yeah, I said. I lived there, too. I told him I was actually involved in one of those tabloid stories, mine involving a landlord who had hired contract killers to murder his brother-in-law and then gets ratted out by the super.
所以我打给他，开始闲聊，就像平常那样。我问他是否经常处理金融犯罪，他很快说他在80年代，在犯罪浪潮期间，在纽约做过杀人案调查，那时候可卡因是王道，谋杀率每年超过2000起。我说，是的，我也住在那儿。我告诉他，我实际上卷入了那些小报故事之一，我的那个案子涉及一名房东雇佣合同杀手谋杀他的姐夫，然后被管理员举报了。
There was a peculiar pause on the phone. Then Moscow said, Allan Stern, West 99th Street? I'm the guy who put him behind bars.
电话那头出现了一段奇怪的停顿。然后莫斯科说，西99街的艾伦·斯特恩？我就是那个把他送进监狱的人。
Right away, of course, we started talking about Bob. I told him the light bulb story. Moscow had a good laugh. And then I went on in the way we residents of 99th Street can do. I finally get to the one about Bob claiming that he had a special exemption from the Brazilian constitution and could murder anyone in Brazil. Again, there was that odd Moscow pause. And then he said, yeah, the thing is, that one's kind of true.
当然，我们立刻开始谈论鲍勃。我讲了灯泡的故事。莫斯科大笑起来。然后我继续讲，用我们99街居民特有的方式。我终于讲到了那个关于鲍勃声称自己有巴西宪法的特别豁免权，可以在巴西谋杀任何人的故事。莫斯科又出现了那种奇怪的停顿。然后他说，是啊，问题在于，那个故事某种程度上是真的。
I asked him, when you were in the military, where were you assigned? I was in the military police.
我问他，你服兵役时被分配到哪儿了？我在宪兵队。
Here's John Moscow, describing Bob's testimony on the witness stand.
这是约翰·莫斯科，描述鲍勃在证人席上的证词。
And what was your job? My job was to locate, interrogate, and execute politically unreliable persons.
你的工作是什么？我的工作是定位、审讯并处决政治上不可靠的人。
Get out of here.
别开玩笑了。
Bob had been in the Death Squad in Brazil. And he was asked, did you kill any people while you were there? Yes. Was it more than one? Yes. Was it more than five? I don't know. What do you mean, you don't know? Well, if you shoot somebody at long range, and they go down, you don't know if they're dead or wounded.
鲍勃曾在巴西的死亡小队服役。有人问他，你在那里杀过人吗？是的。不止一个吗？是的。不止五个吗？我不知道。什么叫你不知道？好吧，如果你从远处射击某人，他们倒下了，你不知道他们是死了还是受了伤。
There comes a point when you realize that beneath all of the fanciful stories, there usually is a substantial amount of truth. He said he came north for his health and perhaps to protect his heart. But he was thinking about high impact lead poisoning. Apparently, a number of-- now he was in his 20s when he was in the Death Squad. And he realized at one point that a substantial number of people in his squad were dead of violent causes, which would be consistent either with their being suicidal in the risks they took or with somebody having a list of the names and where they were located, someone whose relatives had been mishandled. So he decided that leaving was good for his health.
当你意识到在所有虚构故事的背后，通常都有大量真相时，就会有一种感觉。他说他来北方是为了健康，也许是为了保护他的心脏。但他想的是高冲击力的铅中毒。显然，他20多岁在死亡小队时，意识到队里很多人都死于暴力事件，这要么意味着他们是在执行任务中自杀，要么就是有人有一份名单，知道他们的名字和位置，那些被他们伤害过的人的亲属。所以他觉得离开对身体健康有好处。
All those crazy Bob stories we swapped for years, who'd have thought that the truth about Bob would be just as crazy? According to Moscow, not only had Bob been in the Death Squad, but he had been a key figure in the murder of Allan's brother-in-law. Bob was crucial in securing the talents of the two hitmen named Sammy Feet and Crazy Joe. And according to the court documents, Bob was in the boiler room with some of his crew when news of the hit came down. They celebrated with Martini and Rossi. And things really got going when a portable radio just happened to belt out that Queen song. You know the one.
我们交换了多年的那些疯狂的鲍勃故事，谁能想到关于鲍勃的真相竟然同样疯狂？根据莫斯科的说法，鲍勃不仅在死亡小队服役，他还是谋杀艾伦姐夫的关键人物。鲍勃在招募那两名绰号“萨米脚”和“疯狂乔”的杀手方面起到了关键作用。根据法庭文件，当谋杀成功的消息传来时，鲍勃正和他的同伙在锅炉房里。他们用马提尼和罗西苦艾酒庆祝。而当便携式收音机正好放起皇后乐队的那首歌时，气氛真正达到了高潮。你知道是哪首。
[MUSIC - "ANOTHER ONE BITES THE DUST" BY QUEEN]
[音乐 - 皇后乐队的“又一个被咬掉的灰尘”]
The hit was just one of numerous crimes-- brilliant crimes, really-- that Bob and Allan pulled off from that little office. It turns out that when it comes to crime, Bob was incredibly competent. He and Allan set up dummy construction companies. They defrauded the state with counterfeit charges. To force out one tenant, they rewired the electrical outlets to high voltage lines to fry all the apartment appliances. My favorite was their natural gas scam. They put fake cones out on the street and actually jack hammered through the asphalt to a working gas line. They bypassed the meters and in time, eliminated more than $800,000 of Allan's gas bills.
这次谋杀只是鲍勃和艾伦在那间小办公室里策划的众多犯罪——极其天才的犯罪——中的一起。事实证明，谈到犯罪，鲍勃的能力极其出色。他和艾伦成立了虚假的建筑公司。他们用伪造的账单欺诈州政府。为了逼走一个住户，他们把电源插座重新连接到高压线，烧毁了公寓里的所有电器。我最喜欢的是他们的天然气骗局。他们在街上摆了假锥桶，真的用手提钻钻透沥青，接通了正在工作的天然气管。他们绕过了计量表，最终减少了艾伦80多万美元的煤气费。
On top of all this, Bob helped the prosecution snare Allan. Bob tapped Allen's phones. Bob wore a wire. And in court transcripts, Allan calmly weighs the relative merits of buying off some people versus having them killed. And this is what really comes across when you talk to Moscow-- just how wrong all of us were at sizing up Bob and Allan.
最重要的是，鲍勃帮助检方抓住了艾伦。鲍勃监听了艾伦的电话。鲍勃戴了窃听器。在法庭记录中，艾伦冷静地权衡着花钱买通某些人与直接杀掉他们之间的利弊。当你和莫斯科交谈时，你会真正感受到这一点——我们当时对鲍勃和艾伦的判断错得有多离谱。
We had 2,200 homicides in New York, as opposed to fewer than 500, which is what we're on for this year. You had a lot of people talking about killing people. There was a certain rationality and cold-bloodedness about this murder that was just plain different. And I just-- Bob testified under oath at trial. I watched him when he was being cross-examined. And I don't think I'll ever forget. Defense counsel asked him, did you torture men or women? And he said, my specialty was men. And the way he said it, my blood felt about 10 degrees colder. And there was just absolute-- the courtroom-- everyone was persuaded that he meant it.
当时纽约有2200起杀人案，而不是今年的不到500起。有很多人在谈论杀人。这次谋杀有一种冷血的理性，确实与众不同。我——鲍勃在审判时宣誓作证。我看着他接受盘问。我想我永远不会忘记。辩护律师问他，你折磨过男人还是女人？他说，我的专长是男人。他说话的方式，让我的血液感到凉了10度。那一刻，法庭里绝对——每个人都相信他是认真的。
So how did Bob, former Brazilian Death Squad officer, rat out Allan?
那么，身为前巴西死亡小队成员的鲍勃，是怎么举报艾伦的？
Bob, I think, called tips to report the murder.
鲍勃，我想，是打电话举报了这起谋杀案。
Tips?
举报？
Right.
没错。
You mean like the 1-800 number or one of the local crime reporting--
你是说那种1-800号码或者当地的犯罪举报——
[INAUDIBLE] tips or whatever, yeah. So he calls that. And then he goes and makes an appointment and meets with the Major Case Squad.
[听不清]举报电话之类的，是的。所以他打了电话。然后他去预约并见了重大案件调查组。
What drove him to turn Allan in?
是什么促使他举报艾伦的？
Allan and his family had discussed selling the building and moving to Florida. And in the course of that, Allan had discussed having the president and the vice president of the Tenants Association murdered. And Bob figured that Allan was going to have these two guys whacked and blame Bob.
艾伦和他的家人讨论过卖掉这栋楼搬到佛罗里达。在讨论过程中，艾伦商量过要把租户协会的主席和副主席谋杀掉。鲍勃意识到艾伦要干掉这两个家伙，并把责任推给鲍勃。
What year was this?
那是哪一年？
This was 1988.
那是1988年。
Now I only bring that up because there was a-- at one point, there was a rent strike that was going to be put together in my building. And I was the tenant leader of that. I mean, was that the rent problem that Allan was upset about?
我提这个只是因为当时——有一次，我们大楼里要进行租金罢工。我是那个租户领袖。我是说，那是艾伦感到不安的那个租金问题吗？
Unless there was another rent strike.
除非还有另外一场租金罢工。
Wow. So Allan might have actually tried to get me whacked.
哇。所以艾伦可能真的试图干掉我。
Ultimately, Bob went into the police station and admitted his own role in a murder and thought he was going to prison because his perception at the time was that Allan would cause these murders to take place. And so he protected himself by ratting Allan out first.
最终，鲍勃走进警察局，承认了自己在谋杀中的角色，他以为自己要坐牢，因为当时他的看法是，艾伦会导致这些谋杀发生。所以他通过先举报艾伦来保护自己。
So Bob turning state's evidence basically saved my life, or the life of the tenant organizers.
所以鲍勃转为污点证人基本上救了我的命，或者说是租户组织者的命。
That was Bob's thought.
那是鲍勃的想法。
I found Bob. I reached him on the phone, and we had a nice chat. He remembers me as the tall blond guy on the first floor. He wanted to talk to me for this story, but his lawyer told him, not today or ever. And then Bob suggested that I not bother to call back.
我找到了鲍勃。我在电话里联系了他，我们进行了一次愉快的交谈。他记得我是住在一楼的那个高个金发男。他想为这个故事跟我聊聊，但他律师告诉他，今天不行，以后也不行。然后鲍勃建议我别再费心打电话了。
I wanted to ask him about the cattle ranches and being written into the constitution and give those stories a fresh listen, knowing what I know now. And of course, I wanted to know whether I was the one who was going to get whacked. I wasn't the only tenant organizer in the building at the time, but I'll never get that answer now. All I have is another Bob story, full of details I can't confirm, but so delicious that I can't wait to go back to my old pals and tell it to them.
我想问他关于养牛场和被写进宪法的事情，并以我现在的认知重新听听那些故事。当然，我还想知道我是否就是那个差点被干掉的人。当时大楼里不只有我一个租户组织者，但我现在永远得不到答案了。我唯一拥有的又是一个关于鲍勃的故事，充满了无法证实的细节，但又如此美味，我迫不及待地想回到老朋友身边讲给他们听。
So this is one of the lawyers talking to Bob during the trial. When you began your testimony on direct yesterday, you told us about your military experience in Brazil. I would like to--
这是审判期间其中一位律师跟鲍勃的谈话。当你昨天开始直接作证时，你告诉我们你在巴西的军事经历。我想——
Chris and Anne live in Queens now. I read to them the court transcripts that John Moscow had told me about.
克里斯和安妮现在住在皇后区。我给他们读了约翰·莫斯科告诉我的法庭记录。
More than one. Was it more than 10? More than 10. All right, let's go on. Did you torture both men and women? My specialty was men.
不止一个。不止十个吗？不止十个。好吧，继续。你折磨男人和女人吗？我的专长是男人。
Holy [BLEEP].
该死的。
Was he making this up or--
他是编的还是——
No, OK. No, I--
不，好吧。不，我——
This is the testimony that-- this is-- I mean, it's under oath.
这是证词——这是——我是说，这是宣誓作证。
Wow.
哇。
You've taken it to a whole new level, sir. Holy [BLEEP].
你把它带到了一个全新的层面，先生。该死的。
That is scary.
那太可怕了。
Whoa. But it does make you sort of go back and rethink the whole pattern of exchanges you had with him. I never come in-- like, I never said to myself, there's some reality to who this guy says he is. I mean, I used to get furious at him. But to think, oh, I was talking to a murdering torturer--
哇。但这确实让你不得不回去重新思考你和他之间所有交往的模式。我从来没想过——比如，我从来没对自己说，这家伙说自己是谁是有某种真实的。我是说，我曾经对他愤怒极了。但想到，哦，我当时是在跟一个杀人折磨者说话——
He was definitely toying with us.
他绝对是在戏弄我们。
Yeah, but now it's a different level of toying. Instead of just being some [BLEEP] it's like he's a professional.
是的，但现在这是一种不同层面的戏弄。不再仅仅是个混蛋，他是个专业人士。
I feel like-- I'm sitting here amazed now that we weren't killed and tortured. We were only psychologically tortured, but he-- I mean, this could have been a very horrible story.
我觉得——我现在坐在这儿感到震惊，我们竟然没有被杀或者被折磨。我们只是在心理上受到了折磨，但他——我是说，这本来可能是一个非常可怕的故事。
You know what? Our current super is looking much better.
你知道吗？我们现在的管理员看起来好多了。
It doesn't surprise me, in a way.
从某种意义上说，这并不让我惊讶。
Again, here's Kevin.
再来，这是凯文。
I mean, it's like, talk about the banality of evil. He strikes me as one of these Eichmann type characters, who would, in certain contexts, do completely awful, disgusting things. And then if removed from them and put in some more m banal surrounding, would settle back and just be a windy superintendent of a building.
我是说，谈论平庸之恶。他让我感觉就像那种艾希曼式的人物，在特定环境下，会做出完全可怕、令人作呕的事情。然后如果脱离了这些，被放在一些更平庸的环境中，他就会安顿下来，重新成为一个喋喋不休的大楼管理员。
It was kind of interesting, though. After this was all over, after he had testified and Allan was put away, of course, Allan's daughters, I believe, then owned the buildings. So of course, Bob lost his free apartment and his super's position. And it was almost like he kind of deflated.
不过，这倒是挺有趣的。这一切结束之后，在他作证并把艾伦送进去之后，当然，我相信艾伦的女儿们接手了这栋楼。所以，鲍勃当然失去了免费的公寓和管理员职位。他几乎就像瘪了气一样。
Nobody had to talk to him anymore, so he would walk around-- it was almost pathetic. He'd walk up and down the block and say hi. And people would just kind of go by-- nod to him and go by. And then after a short time after this, he just wasn't around anymore. He was gone. And I have no idea where he went to. Where is he anyway? Did you find out anyway?
没人再需要跟他说话了，所以他就在街上走来走去——这几乎令人同情。他会在街区里走来走去打招呼。而人们只会匆匆走过——向他点个头就走掉。在这之后不久，他就不见了。他走了。我不知道他去了哪儿。无论如何他到底在哪儿？你查到了吗？
He's an elevator inspector in New York City.
他是纽约市的一名电梯检查员。
Good God. We're all in trouble now.
老天爷啊。我们现在都有麻烦了。
I found Allan also at his website, allanstern.net. He's been appealing his conviction for over 15 years. He makes the case that he's innocent. His argument is that the entire story of Sammy Feet and Crazy Joe and the explanation of the brother-in-law's murder and all the rest of it is hearsay, a grandiose fiction. In other words, Allan is saying, he can top us all. That he's the victim of the most outlandish Bob story ever told.
我也在他的网站allanstern.net上找到了艾伦。他已经对他的定罪上诉了15年多。他坚称自己无罪。他的论点是，关于萨米脚和疯狂乔的整个故事以及对谋杀姐夫的解释等等，都是传闻，是一种华丽的虚构。换句话说，艾伦在说，他能超越我们所有人。说他是史上最离谱的鲍勃故事的受害者。
Jack Hitt. He now lives in New Haven in a house, where he is his own super. He's also the co-host of the Peabody Award-winning podcast Uncivil. If you haven't heard it, seriously, give it a try. He's currently developing a new podcast. It's been many years since we first reported this story. In 2014, Allan Stern was released from prison. Bob, as far as we can tell, is no longer an elevator inspector for the city of New York. John Moscow is now practicing criminal law in Manhattan.
杰克·希特。他现在住在纽黑文的一栋房子里，在那里他自己就是管理员。他也是皮博迪奖得主播客《Uncivil》的联合主持人。如果你还没听过，认真地说，试着听听看。他目前正在开发一个新的播客。距离我们首次报道这个故事已经过去很多年了。2014年，艾伦·斯特恩从监狱获释。据我们所知，鲍勃已不再担任纽约市的电梯检查员。约翰·莫斯科现在在曼哈顿从事刑事法律工作。
Coming up, a super gets a crush. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一个管理员产生了爱慕之情。那是在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Super. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Super Duper. We now move from a story about an East Coast super to a story about a West Coast super, from Alex Blumberg.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是《管理员》。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《超级管理员》。我们现在从一个关于东海岸管理员的故事转向一个关于西海岸管理员的故事，来自亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
Josh lives in a Spanish courtyard building in Los Angeles, a city in which even apartment buildings act like they're on TV.
乔希住在洛杉矶的一栋西班牙庭院式建筑里，那是一个连公寓大楼都表现得像是在演电视的城市。
It's a little bit like Melrose Place, a lot of communal activity. And sort of presiding above it is the super. He's not really a super like you would have in maybe a larger building or a larger city. He's--
这有点像《梅尔罗斯广场》，有很多社区活动。而站在它之上的人是管理员。他并不是那种你在更大建筑或更大城市里可能拥有的那种管理员。他——
A larger city than LA?
比洛杉矶更大的城市？
All right. I guess more like a dense urban city, is what I meant to say. But so he doesn't have, like, a tool belt and show up and fix things. But he'll sort of call the guy who does that. And he takes the rent. And he is kind of a solitary guy, for the most part. He sort of likes to spend a lot of time reading and stuff. So he just kind of like hangs out up there in the building.
好吧。我想我是指人口更稠密的城市。所以他没有那种工具带，也不会出现修这修那。但他会叫人来做那些事。他负责收租。大部分情况下，他是个孤独的人。他喜欢花很多时间看书什么的。所以他只是在那栋楼里闲逛。
Josh and the rest of the tenants in the building like their super, whom we'll call Dave, and hung out with him. At the time of the story, Dave was going through chemotherapy for leukemia. And occasionally, he'd call different residents to ask for help with things. One Christmas, he contacted Josh.
乔希和楼里的其他住户喜欢他们的管理员——我们叫他戴夫——并和他一起闲逛。在这个故事发生时，戴夫正在接受白血病的化疗。偶尔，他会给不同的住户打电话寻求帮助。有一年圣诞节，他联系了乔希。
He calls and he says, this really weird thing happened. And I came over to his apartment. He had this orchid that was sitting on the table next to him. And he said, well, I had this visitor. And it was a very strange visit. And he started to tell me that a couple of months ago, in between chemotherapy treatments-- he'd had two chemotherapy treatments. And so he was out somewhere, and he was in his Land Cruiser, I think he has.
他打电话过来说，发生了一件非常奇怪的事。我去了他的公寓。他旁边桌子上放着一盆兰花。他说，好吧，我有了一位访客。那是一次非常奇怪的访问。他开始告诉我，几个月前，在化疗期间——他已经接受了两次化疗。所以他当时在外面某个地方，开着他的陆地巡洋舰，我想他有这么一辆车。
And he was at this gas station, and he sees this woman pulls up in a big black Escalade. And she's on the opposite side of the pumps as him. She was an older woman, but he said very elegant and attractive in the elegant older woman way. And she had fancy clothes and, like, furs. And I think he mentioned that she had espadrilles on. And she was in this black Escalade, so she seemed to be classy or something, or well off.
他在那个加油站，看到一个女人开着一辆黑色大凯雷德停了下来。她在油泵的另一侧。她是一位年纪较大的女士，但他说是那种优雅且吸引人的年纪较大的女士。她穿着时髦，比如皮草。我记得他提到她穿了草编鞋。她开着这辆黑色的凯雷德，所以她看起来很有格调或者说很有钱。
And so they're standing there at the pumps, and they start chatting. She initiates conversation with him, and they're getting on very well. And then he told me that she said something about him being bald, which was from the chemotherapy. And she said, are you bald from the chemotherapy? Or are you just bald because you think it's sexy? Something like that. And he was not offended by that. He thought it was kind of like this romantic repartee or something.
他们站在油泵旁，开始聊天。她主动找他搭话，他们聊得很投机。然后他告诉我，她说了点关于他秃头的事，那是化疗导致的。她说，你是化疗秃的吗？还是你觉得秃头很性感？诸如此类的。他并没有被冒犯。他觉得这是一种浪漫的应答。
And then she gives him a card. And the card was sort of like an old style carte de visite that just had her name. It wasn't a business card that had a company or information on it. It was just sort of like a calling card that you used to leave at the door of Count Vronsky's estate when you would stop by or something. And so he remembered thinking that that was kind of a classy touch.
然后她递给他一张名片。那张名片就像那种旧式的访问卡，上面只有她的名字。它不是印有公司或信息的商业名片。它就像那种你以前去拜访沃伦斯基伯爵庄园时留下的名片。他记得认为那是一种有格调的举动。
And very mysterious.
而且非常神秘。
Very mysterious. And so then he gave her his information. And they parted ways.
非常神秘。然后他把信息给了她。他们分开了。
Until Christmas, two months after their first meeting at the gas station, when the mysterious lady called out of the blue. She'd asked how Dave was, and he told her about his recent health problems. An infection from the chemotherapy had turned serious, and he'd spent a couple of weeks in a hospital in a near coma.
直到圣诞节，在他们在加油站初次见面两个月后，那位神秘女士突然打来了电话。她问戴夫怎么样了，他告诉了她最近的健康问题。化疗引发的感染变得严重，他在医院昏迷了近两周。
That's terrible, the lady said. Is there anything I can do? Can I come by and visit? Dave said yes, and so she'd arrived that morning dressed in the same elegant manner as at the gas station, bearing the orchid which Dave now had on his table. And they'd sat and chatted.
太糟糕了，女士说。我能做点什么吗？我可以去看看你吗？戴夫说了好，所以她那天早上穿着和在加油站时一样优雅的方式到达了，带着戴夫现在桌上的那盆兰花。他们坐下来聊天。
Somehow, the topic of fate came up. And that was the point when she said, I know this is kind of a weird time, but I actually have something I wanted to share with you. And he says, what's that? And she says that she was abroad with this group of investors who had developed this really interesting investment opportunity. And she says, I know that this is a weird time. But this is very exciting, so I feel like I should just let you in on this investment opportunity right now.
不知怎么的，谈到了命运这个话题。那是她开口说，我知道这可能不是时候，但我真的有些事想跟你分享。他说，什么事？她说她当时在国外，跟着一群开发了一个非常有趣的投资机会的投资者在一起。她说，我知道这不是时候。但这非常令人兴奋，我觉得我应该现在就让你参与这个投资机会。
He was a little surprised. And but he said, oh, all right. So what's the investment opportunity? And she said, well, I've gotten involved with this very canny group of investors. And it seems that they have located this snowman that can bench press 400 pounds.
他有点惊讶。但他说了，哦，好吧。那是什么投资机会？她说，嗯，我加入了一群非常精明的投资者。似乎他们已经找到了这个可以卧推400磅的雪人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What?
什么？
Yeah, so-- I said-- so then I'm asking, OK-- well, what do you mean? What kind of a snowman?
是啊，所以——我说——那我问了，好吧——你是什么意思？什么样的雪人？
It's hard to exactly figure out what the proper follow-up question is.
很难确切找出合适的跟进问题是什么。
Yeah. And so I said, well, OK, so, like, it's the Abominable Snowman. He's like, no, no, no. She said it's a totally normal snowman with a carrot nose and the coal for the eyes and a top hat and everything. It's just that this snowman can bench press 400 pounds.
是啊。于是我说，好吧，所以，那是大脚怪吗？他像是说，不，不，不。她说那是完全正常的雪人，有胡萝卜鼻子、煤块眼睛、高礼帽什么的。只是这个雪人可以卧推400磅。
And so then-- but so I'm saying, well, OK, but what-- what's the investment opportunity? Is he running a hedge fund or what? I mean, I don't understand. And then he said, no. See, what happened is the investors, they've got it all worked out. They're going to put together a variety show with the snowman as the lead act. And then they're going to take the snowman show on tour.
于是——但我说，好吧，但是什么——投资机会是什么？他在经营对冲基金还是什么？我是说，我不明白。然后他说，不。看，发生的是投资者们，他们已经全盘计划好了。他们要组织一场以雪人为主角的综艺节目。然后他们要带着雪人秀去巡回演出。
And so the investment opportunity is the geographic territorial rights to the show. So when the show goes to different states, you get to reap the rewards if you've bought into the rights to the show. So the woman said that she had already-- she got in on the ground floor with this thing. And so she got California and Nevada, like the west. So he said that the United States was all snapped up. So but now Indonesia is wide open.
所以投资机会是节目的地理区域权利。所以当节目去到不同的州时，如果你买了节目的权利，你就可以获得回报。所以女士说她已经——她在这件事上抢占了先机。所以她拿下了加州和内华达州，就像西部地区。他说美国那边都已经抢光了。但现在印尼那边完全空着。
For the variety show starring the weightlifting snowman?
为那个由举重雪人主演的综艺节目？
The weightlifting snowman. Yeah, so the price for Indonesia's territorial rights to the show, to the snowman show, were not cheap. It was like $30,000 or something.
举重雪人。是的，所以印尼地区的那个节目的权利，那个雪人秀的权利，可不便宜。大约是3万美元或者什么的。
OK. So what I don't understand, though, is if you actually discovered a snowman that had somehow become animated, it seems like the last sort of thing that you would do is then design a variety show for it.
好吧。但我还是不明白的是，如果你真的发现了一个以某种方式变得有生命的雪人，这看起来是你最不可能做的事情，那就是为它设计一个综艺节目。
I know. Well, right. That is what I was asking him. I said, well, listen. Wait, hold on a second. Isn't there going to be-- there's going to be a lot more important things happening than publicity for your variety show. Because the whole world is going to change. Science will have to readjust everything it's ever known. All the various theologians of the world are going to have to deal with the news, like animated snowman world.
我知道。嗯，没错。那就是我问他的。我说，听着。等等，等一下。难道不会有——会有比综艺节目的宣传更重要的事情发生吗？因为整个世界都会改变。科学将不得不重新调整它所知道的一切。世界上所有的神学家都必须处理这个新闻，比如有生命的雪人世界。
Right.
对。
They would have to really sort a lot of things out, just even the basic question of, well, how-- did the snowman roll himself up into three balls and find a carrot nose? And like, how did the investors find the snowman? That's the other thing that I was curious about. Were they driving around the woods and they just saw this snowman lifting logs, and they high-fived each other and said, all right, we've got a variety show? Like they're in a caravan of black suburbans with their cigars, like, we did it.
他们不得不梳理很多事情，哪怕只是基本问题，比如，嗯，怎么——雪人把自己滚成了三个球并找到了一个胡萝卜鼻子？而且，投资者是怎么发现雪人的？那是另一件我好奇的事。他们是不是开车穿过树林，刚好看到这个雪人在举木头，然后他们击掌说，好了，我们有个综艺节目了？就像他们开着黑色雪佛兰郊区车队，抽着雪茄说，我们做到了。
The weird thing was even though Dave found the story of a weightlifting snowman just as preposterous as Josh did, he seem somehow persuaded by this mysterious woman. He said it was hard to explain, but he felt like he'd known her his entire life. And he looked at life differently now, anyway.
奇怪的是，尽管戴夫觉得那个举重雪人的故事和乔希觉得的一样荒谬，但他似乎被那位神秘女士说服了。他说很难解释，但他觉得他好像认识她一辈子了。无论如何，他现在对生活的看法不同了。
He said something about how after-- when you get cancer or something like that, a serious illness, you just start to re-evaluate things. What might have seemed risky beforehand isn't now. And so he said, I kind of just felt like maybe there was a reason to take a risk. Maybe there's a reason I met the woman at the Shell station, and maybe this is kind of a risk to take. And then that's basically when he said, so I wrote her a check for $30,000.
他说了一些关于在——当你得了癌症或者类似的事情时，严重疾病，你只是开始重新评估事情。之前可能觉得冒险的事情现在不觉得了。所以他说，我只是觉得也许有一个理由去冒险。也许我遇到那个壳牌加油站的女士是有原因的，也许这就是一种要冒的险。基本上就在那时他说，所以我给她开了一张3万美元的支票。
Oh my God. What did you think?
天哪。你怎么想的？
I was alarmed. And I was worried that it was a con, and obviously.
我很震惊。我担心这是一个骗局，很明显。
Right.
对。
But I kind of actually was a little bit convinced by his whole theory. I was thinking like maybe it's not so bad.
但我其实被他的整个理论稍微说服了一点。我想也许没那么糟。
Right. Thinking it's sort of his money and--
对。觉得那是他的钱并且——
Right. If that's how he is going to sort of embrace life after cancer, then who am I to say?
对。如果这就是他在癌症之后拥抱生活的方式，那么我有什么资格评价呢？
Right.
对。
So I kind of felt like I had to accept that.
所以我感觉我必须接受这一点。
Over the next year, Josh told the weightlifting snowman story to everybody he could. He loved it. And his audiences seemed to love it, too. At one point, he decided, with Dave's consent, to write it up for a magazine humor section. The final step in publishing it was to have it fact-checked. And so the magazine called Dave.
在接下来的一年里，乔希把举重雪人的故事讲给每一个他能讲的人听。他很喜欢。而他的听众似乎也喜欢。有一次，在戴夫的同意下，他决定把它写下来给一本杂志的幽默版。出版它的最后一步是进行事实核查。所以杂志社给戴夫打了电话。
He called me and said, so the magazine's fact-checkers called. And I told them what I'm about to tell you, which is that I actually made that whole story up. And there was no lady with the carte de visite or espadrilles or furs or the snowman.
他打电话给我说，杂志社的事实核查员打电话来了。我告诉了他们我正要告诉你这件事，那就是我实际上编造了那个整个故事。根本没有带着访问卡或草编鞋或皮草的女士，也没有雪人。
Did you ask him why?
你问他为什么了吗？
He just thought that it would be a story that would amuse me, and he was absolutely correct. I guess he had no idea how successfully that story was going to appeal to me. And so, I mean, I kind of bought it. I mean, the idea of you lived to be in your middle ages, and you kind of never took any risks, and then things get totally-- the perspective refocuses in such a way that a weightlifting snowman makes as much sense as anything else. I kind of like it.
他只是觉得那会是一个让我开心的故事，而且他是完全正确的。我想他不知道那个故事会多么成功地吸引我。所以，我是说，我有点相信了。我是说，你活到了中年，你从未冒过任何险，然后事情变得完全——视角发生了如此的改变，以至于一个举重雪人就像任何其他事情一样合理。我有点喜欢它。
You kind of like it that he created a world in which it made sense to spend $30,000 on a weightlifting snowman?
你有点喜欢他创造了一个花费3万美元在举重雪人身上变得合理的世界？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
Huh. In a weird sense, you were the con.
哈。从某种奇怪的意义上说，你才是那个被骗的人。
Yeah, I mean, it was like a double reverse reveal at the end of some movie, where I would have been writing some check for like a million dollars at the end, right? Because somehow I got sucked into the whole thing.
是的，我是说，这就像某些电影结尾的二次反转揭露，我会因为某种原因在最后开一张百万美元的支票，对吧？因为我不知何故被卷进了整个事情里。
But you did get sucked into it. You wanted it so bad. I think part of what I love about it-- and maybe you do, too-- is just sort of the image of the snowman, like this stick-armed, carrot-nosed snowman actually just lying on a weight bench in the middle of the Siberian wood.
但你确实被卷进去了。你太想要它了。我想我喜欢它的一部分原因——也许你也一样——只是那种雪人的意象，像那个挥舞着棍子手臂、长着胡萝卜鼻子的雪人，实际上正躺在西伯利亚树林中间的举重凳上。
Well, also bench pressing in particular is like, you require a bench. So I still don't understand. Let's say they found the snowman in the woods, then did he have his own bench? Was it made out of snow? He wasn't doing squats.
好吧，特别是卧推，你需要一个凳子。所以我还是不明白。假设他们在树林里发现了雪人，那么他有他自己的凳子吗？它是雪做的吗？他当时不是在做深蹲。
Alex Blumberg talking with Josh Bearman. These days, Alex runs the podcasting company Gimlet Media, the home of Reply All and Heavyweight and The Nod and many other shows. Josh has been a regular contributor to our show. And these days, he's a producer in the new Apple TV series Little America, which comes out next month. Ken Hunter was the super who made up that story about the snowman and who had a real talent for telling outrageous and ridiculous stories. There's no easy way to say this. He died a few years ago.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格与乔希·贝尔曼的对话。这些天，亚历克斯经营着播客公司Gimlet Media，它是《Reply All》、《Heavyweight》、《The Nod》和许多其他节目的基地。乔希一直是我们节目的常客。这些天，他是Apple TV新剧《小美国》的制作人，该剧下个月上映。肯·亨特是那个编造了雪人故事，并且确实很有天赋讲述离谱和荒谬故事的管理员。没有简单的方法来表达这一点。他几年前去世了。
Act Three, Please Re-Lease Me. That's re-lease me. We changed the names of the people in this story to protect the tenants involved.
第三幕，《请重新出租我》。那是重新出租我。为了保护相关住户，我们改变了这个故事中人物的名字。
Sometimes somebody tells you your future, and you do not want to believe it. You can't believe it. When Dennis was 21, he became the super of this apartment building that his dad owned, a big 100-unit building in what was once a rough neighborhood. And his dad gave him this warning, father to son, super to super, about the tenants.
有时候有人告诉你你的未来，而你不愿相信。你无法相信。丹尼斯21岁时，成了他父亲拥有的那栋公寓楼的管理员，那是一栋100单元的大楼，位于曾经的一个治安混乱的街区。他父亲给了他这个警告，父亲对儿子，管理员对管理员，关于住户的警告。
They will make a good person bad. Maybe you go into the landlording and business and you have good intentions and you're a good person. But people-- the lies they tell you, the tricks they play on you, the damage they do to your property, you will eventually lose that innocence and become a meaner person. I was like, wow. That kind of sucks. I hope that never happens to me.
他们会让一个好人变坏。也许你进入房地产业做生意，你有良好的意图，你是个好人。但人们——他们告诉你的谎言，他们对你玩的把戏，他们对你财产造成的破坏，你最终会失去那份纯真，变得更刻薄。我说，哇。那真是太烂了。我希望那种事永远不会发生在我身上。
Dennis always figured he'd be a different kind of super than his dad anyway. His dad had been a plumber. Nothing made him happier than fixing the plumbing and the washing machines in the building. And his dad had some old world ways of doing things. If somebody was causing trouble, selling drugs or making a ruckus, he'd pound on doors and get in their face if he had to. The neighborhood was slowly improving, but when he first bought the building, people didn't care what the lease said or didn't say, and he had to deal with a lot of things man to man.
丹尼斯总是认为无论如何他会成为一个与他父亲不同的管理员。他父亲以前是个水管工。没什么比修理楼里的水管和洗衣机让他更快乐的了。而且他父亲有一些老派的处事方法。如果有人在找麻烦，卖毒品或制造骚乱，他会敲门，必要时会冲到他们面前。街区在慢慢改善，但当他刚买下这栋楼时，人们根本不在乎租约写了什么或没写什么，他必须亲力亲为处理很多事情。
Dennis, meanwhile, was just out of college. His dad had scrimped and sacrificed to put him through Catholic schools, all the way from elementary up through his undergraduate degree. His mom-- his parents were split up-- his mom had always been a devout Catholic, communion every day. And all that stuff that the Jesuits taught Dennis in school about being a good person, he took it to heart.
与此同时，丹尼斯刚从大学毕业。他父亲省吃俭用，送他上了天主教学校，从小学一直到本科毕业。他母亲——他父母分开了——他母亲一直是一位虔诚的天主教徒，每天做弥撒。耶稣会教士在学校教给丹尼斯关于做一个好人的所有东西，他都记在了心里。
One of the things that go into the Jesuit University is just like, they want you to be men and women for others. Not that everything I did, I tried to live up to that high standard, because I know I couldn't. But that was definitely in the back of my head.
进入耶稣会大学的事情之一就是，他们希望你成为服务于他人的男人和女人。并不是说我做的每一件事都达到了那个高标准，因为我知道我做不到。但那绝对在我的脑海里。
Which brings us to our story. At first, the super job went great. People liked Dennis. He got Christmas cards from families in the building. But there was this one couple. They had lived in the building for almost 20 years, since back when his dad first bought the place.
这就引出了我们的故事。起初，管理员的工作进行得很顺利。人们喜欢丹尼斯。他从楼里的家庭那里收到圣诞贺卡。但有一对夫妇。他们在那栋楼里住了近20年，从他父亲刚买下那个地方时就在了。
They were long-term tenants. They were good tenants. They were nice people. In the beginning, it wasn't too much bad you could say about them.
他们是长期住户。他们是好住户。他们是好人。起初，关于他们没什么坏话可说。
And your dad liked them.
而且你父亲喜欢他们。
Yeah, my dad liked them, yeah. He lived below them, actually, so he liked them. Literally lived right below them. My freshman year of high school, I lived with my father, so I lived below them, too, for a year. And so I saw them, and they knew who I was. I mean, even before that, even before high school, when we were little kids, we'd be running around, playing in the courtyard, hanging from the trees. But yeah, I mean, they were a regular fixture.
是的，我父亲喜欢他们。他实际上住在他们下面，所以他喜欢他们。字面上就住在他们正下方。我高一那年，我和父亲住在一起，所以我一年也住在他们下面。所以我见到了他们，他们认识我。我是说，在那之前，甚至在高一之前，当我们还是小孩时，我们在庭院里跑来跑去玩，在树上挂着。但是的，我是说，他们是常规住户。
But everything for this couple changed when their daughter died. The woman quit her job to go to school. They threw all of their savings into that. But she had trouble with the classes, couldn't make the grade. And things just kept going downhill from there. She started drinking. They got behind on their rent.
但这对夫妇的一切在他们女儿去世后改变了。那位女士辞职去上学。他们把所有的积蓄都投入了进去。但她在功课上有困难，没能达到分数线。从那以后情况就一直走下坡路。她开始喝酒。他们的房租迟交了。
She'd drop off a check to me. And then a day later or two days later, she'd call me and say, hey, did you deposit that check yet? And I was like, no, we haven't deposited it yet. Well, could you tear up that check and let me-- I'll give you another check. Forget about that check. And so then we'd tear up that check, and she'd bring down another check. And then that check would bounce. And I think they got to maybe like $4,000 in the hole.
她会把支票给我。然后一两天后，她会打电话给我说，嘿，你把那张支票存了吗？我当时说，不，还没存。那你能撕掉那张支票让我——我会给你另一张支票。忘了那张支票吧。所以我们就撕掉那张支票，她又带了一张支票下来。然后那张支票也跳票了。我想他们可能亏了大约4000美元。
Oh, wow. So they were behind $4,000 in like--
哦，哇。所以他们拖欠了4000美元，在——
Like six months.
大约六个月的时间里。
Six months, yeah. A half year behind.
六个月，是的。拖欠了半年。
Yeah.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
I was like, Dad, we got to kick these people out. We got to get rid of them. And my dad was very reluctant to do that. And he was like, work with them. Work it out. Work with them.
我对父亲说，我们必须把这些人赶走。我们必须摆脱他们。我父亲很不情愿那样做。他说，和他们合作。解决它。和他们合作。
Now why? Like, why?
为什么要这么做？为什么要？
Well, he knew that her husband had a good job. And he knew that they had money coming in and that you could get money out of them, basically.
嗯，他知道她丈夫有一份好工作。他知道他们有钱进来，基本上你可以从他们那里拿到钱。
Oh, I didn't realize that. So it becomes a test of you. The problem wasn't them. Because they've got the money. The problem is you, his son.
哦，我没意识到这一点。所以这成了对你的考验。问题不在于他们。因为他们有钱。问题在于你，他的儿子。
Yeah, so it's like, how good are you?
是的，所以这就像是，你到底有多好？
Dennis wanted to do right by his dad. He wanted to do a good job. Remember he had never had a job before. He was still living with his mom, and now he was in charge of his dad's business. When it came to this couple, he was just flailing around. And he wasn't exactly sure how to get money out of them. But he decided he was going to do it. And he remembered his Jesuit teachers.
丹尼斯想对他父亲尽责。他想做好工作。记住他以前从未有过工作。他当时还和他母亲住在一起，现在他负责他父亲的生意。当谈到这对夫妇时，他简直乱了阵脚。他不确定怎么才能从他们那里拿到钱。但他决定他要做到。他想起了他的耶稣会老师。
I thought to myself. I'm like, it wasn't my job to ease these people through this or get them through it. But I know that if I was in that situation, if I was down on my luck, that I would want somebody to cut me that break or cut me that slack.
我对自己说。我想，让他们安稳度过或渡过难关不是我的工作。但我知道，如果我处在那种情况下，如果我运气不好，我会希望有人能给我那种宽限。
So he sat down and he created a payment plan for them, a few hundred bucks every paycheck. But it was incredibly hard to make them stick to it. They had excuses. They couldn't do it. So he sat them down again, and they made up an agreement. And this time, they put it in writing. And then after month upon month of struggle-- it took over a year-- they finally paid it all back.
所以他坐下来为他们制定了还款计划，每个发薪日几百块。但要让他们坚持下去极其困难。他们有各种借口。他们做不到。所以他再次让他们坐下来，达成了一项协议。这一次，他们把它写了下来。经过几个月的挣扎——花了超过一年——他们终于把钱全还上了。
Then things were OK for a while, but slowly but surely, started falling back into their own ways. And basically what I think it was the alcohol, basically. I remember vividly that she would come down to the laundry room. The laundry room was just outside the office. And she would go to the vending machine and buy can of pop after can of pop after can of pop.
然后事情平静了一阵，但慢慢地，确定地，又开始走回老路。基本上我认为是酒精，基本上。我清楚记得她会下到洗衣房。洗衣房就在办公室外面。她会去自动售货机买一罐又一罐又一罐汽水。
And I always thought that was so weird. I was like, why is she buying, like, eight cans of Sprite or Coke when we're right next door to Walgreens, and she can just go buy a 12-pack? And I think what it was, was she was just getting Cokes to mix drinks with up in her apartment. I just remembered that being so weird.
我一直觉得那太奇怪了。我想，为什么她要买八罐雪碧或可乐，明明我们就挨着沃尔格林，她可以直接去买一打？我想原因就是，她买可乐是为了带回公寓掺酒喝。我只记得那太奇怪了。
So Dennis watched and worried. He worried a lot. Anybody who knew Dennis that time would tell you. It was all he talked about. He'd go out with his friends, and this is what would be on his mind. What should he do? Was he being a sucker? What was going on with this couple?
所以丹尼斯看着，担忧着。他非常担忧。任何当时认识丹尼斯的人都会告诉你。那是他挂在嘴边的话。他和朋友出去，这就是他心里想的事。他该怎么办？他是不是个傻瓜？这对夫妇到底怎么了？
It was the kind of worrying that you might expect from a family member or something. And of course, he was just the super, the property manager. And things got worse. At one point, another tenant found the wife passed out in the hallway of the building, lying there like she was dead, covered in vomit. Dennis ran to her side.
那是你可能从家庭成员身上预期的那种担忧。当然，他只是管理员，物业经理。情况变得更糟。有一次，另一个住户发现那位妻子昏倒在楼道里，像死了一样躺在那里，身上全是呕吐物。丹尼斯跑向她身边。
And I was like, oh my God. What's wrong here? What happened to you? And she's just like, [GROANING]. She can't talk to me. She can't put a sentence together. She's just slurring all her words.
我说，噢天哪。怎么了？你发生了什么？她只是，[呻吟]。她没法跟我说话。她连一句完整的话都说不出来。她只是口齿不清。
And so I was like, what do I do? I'm like, do I take her to the hospital? Do I call an ambulance? Like, well, what do I do? And anyway, she's like, I just need to go to bed. And so she was too drunk to basically open her door.
所以我说，我该怎么办？我是说，我送她去医院吗？我打救护车吗？我该怎么办？无论如何，她说，我只是需要睡觉。于是她醉得基本上打不开自己的门。
So I got her into bed. And she's in bed, and she's laying on her back. And I'm like, I've heard stories. Like, this is how Jimi Hendrix died or something like that. And I'm like, what if she pukes again? Is she going to choke on her puke?
所以我把她扶上床。她躺在床上，平躺着。我想，我听过故事。比如，吉米·亨德里克斯就是这么死的之类的。我想，要是她又吐了怎么办？她会被自己的呕吐物呛死吗？
Finally I get a hold of her husband, and he's like, all right, I'll take care of it, I'll take care of it. But he's at work, and who knows when he's going to get home to take care of this? I'm down in the office, I'm trying to do work.
最终我联系上了她丈夫，他说，好吧，我会处理的，我会处理的。但他还在上班，谁知道他什么时候回来处理这事？我在办公室里，试图干活。
And so I went back up and checked on her a couple of times. And she's sleeping, and she's breathing. And so then I go back down, and I can't get any work done because I was like, God, if this lady dies, I'm never going to forgive myself. I just remember that being a really terrifying experience.
于是我回去看了她几次。她在睡觉，有呼吸。所以我回到楼下，没法干活，因为我想，上帝，如果这个女人死了，我永远不会原谅自己。我只记得那是一次非常恐怖的经历。
It's so weird because part of it is like, you have this business relationship with these people. But you're there in their building. Like, you're there in their house. Like, you own their house, you know? And so it's so personal.
太奇怪了，因为部分原因就像是，你和这些人有这种商业关系。但你就在他们的楼里。就像，你就在他们的房子里。就像，你拥有他们的房子，你知道吗？所以这太私人了。
Yeah. Well, you definitely can't avoid it, so you've lived side by side with them. It becomes more of a neighbor-to-neighbor relationship.
是的。嗯，你绝对无法避免，所以你和他们并肩生活。这变成了更多的邻里关系。
They were slipping on the rent. They'd plead with them. And it was always something. They had to pay other bills. Christmas or Thanksgiving coming up. They asked for extensions. And he was so inside their lives that at one point, he said, sure, they could pay a little later if he could see their tax forms to see what it is that they actually earn. And they showed him, $50,000 a year, which totally got under his skin.
他们在租金上滑坡。他们哀求他。总是有些理由。他们要付别的账单。圣诞节或感恩节要到了。他们请求延期。他太深入他们的生活了，有一次他说，当然，如果能看看他们的税单来了解他们到底挣多少钱，他们可以晚点付。他们给他看了，一年5万美元，这完全让他感到反感。
I was like, you know what? Why can't they pay me? And I started basically putting pen to paper and running some numbers. And I say to the lady-- I'm like, look. Come down to the office. Bring your bills, and we'll do a budget. And I'll show you that you can afford to pay your rent. And after we literally picked every little nit picky thing there could be money that they could spend money on, like kitty litter, laundry, transportation to and from work for her husband, we had like $3,000 left over. And I was like, look, you can afford this apartment.
我说，你知道吗？他们为什么不能付钱给我？我开始基本上拿笔在纸上计算数字。我对那位女士说——我说，听着。到办公室来。带上你的账单，我们来做个预算。我会让你看到你付得起房租。在我们逐一挑剔了所有他们可能花的钱之后，比如猫砂、洗衣、她丈夫的交通费，我们还剩下3000美元。我说，听着，你们付得起这个公寓。
So did that help? Did they end up paying the rent on time for the few months after that?
那有帮助吗？他们在那之后的几个月里最终按时交房租了吗？
No, it didn't help.
不，没用。
Wow, that's quite a lesson right there.
哇，那真是个深刻的教训。
Yeah. It ended up getting really frustrating. And in the end, I was losing my patience, and I was getting really, really mad. She started running out of excuses. And she'd be like, well, my husband borrowed money from people at work. And he's got to pay them back. And that made me really mad.
是的。结果变得非常令人沮丧。最后，我失去了耐心，我变得非常非常生气。她开始借口用光了。她说，嗯，我丈夫从同事那里借了钱。他必须还给他们。这让我非常生气。
I was like, look. You know what? You guys have been taking advantage of me. You've been playing me like a fiddle. And that's it. I'm not taking a back seat anymore. You guys get caught up. You start paying on time, or I'm going to kick you out. And so I was in July and August telling them, like, look. I don't care if it's Christmas. I don't care if it's Thanksgiving. I don't care if it's the holidays. I'm going to kick you out.
我说，听着。你知道吗？你们一直在占我的便宜。你们一直把我当傻子玩。够了。我不再做退让了。你们得补上。你们得开始按时支付，否则我就要把你们赶出去。所以在7月和8月我告诉他们，看。我不在乎是不是圣诞节。我不在乎是不是感恩节。我不在乎是不是假期。我要把你们赶出去。
Can I ask what is going to be a really naive question? If you have a 100-unit building, like, in reality, how important is it that you get the rent on one unit?
我能问一个很天真的问题吗？如果你有一栋100单元的楼，现实中，拿到一个单元的租金有多重要？
Well, I guess in the grand scheme of things, it's not going to make you or break you. But I mean, that's the deal. If you can't afford it, then I tell them, look, if you can't afford it, move to a smaller apartment. I'll give you a smaller apartment. But they didn't want to move. They did not want to move.
嗯，我想从宏观角度来看，它不会让你成功或失败。但我是说，这就是交易。如果你负担不起，我就告诉他们，看，如果你负担不起，搬到一个更小的公寓去。我会给你一个更小的公寓。但他们不想搬。他们不想搬。
By the time Dennis was drawing up a budget for this couple, he'd been at it on and off for six years with them. And his feelings would vacillate all over the place. But his dad-- the very man who told him how running a building hardens you-- his dad never wavered in support of the couple.
当丹尼斯在为这对夫妇制定预算时，他已经和他们断断续续打了六年交道了。他的感受会摇摆不定。但他父亲——那个告诉他管理大楼如何让人变硬心肠的同一个人——他父亲始终支持这对夫妇。
My dad and I would have battles. Like, we should kick them out. We should kick them out. My dad would be like, no, I don't want to kick them out. I'd be like, look, these people are way behind their rent. You gotta kick them out. Dad, just get rid of these people.
我父亲和我会有争执。比如，我们应该把他们赶出去。我们应该把他们赶出去。我父亲会说，不，我不想把他们赶出去。我会说，看，这些人拖欠了这么多租金。你必须把他们赶出去。爸爸，摆脱这些人吧。
And we'd talk, and he'd reminisce about the stories. And one of the stories he tells me is that he went to the wake for the child that passed away. And he said to-- I think it was like the sister of the lady's husband. He's like, I used to hear the baby crying all night long, just crying and crying and crying. And the gentleman's sister is like, well, you're not going to have to hear the baby crying anymore. She turned around and walked away from him.
我们交谈，他会追忆往事。他讲给我的故事之一是他去参加了那个去世孩子的葬礼。他对——我想是那位女士丈夫的姐妹说。他说，我以前整晚都能听到宝宝在哭，一直哭一直哭一直哭。那位男士的姐妹说，好吧，你再也不用听到宝宝哭了。她转身走开了。
Oh, she took it completely wrong.
哦，她完全理解错了。
Yeah, my dad didn't mean it like, that kid was keeping me awake all night. Oh, thank God, now I can sleep. He's had kids of his own, and so he might know what it's like to see your kid in pain. So that, for him, was very, I think, just an emotional bond, where it was like, these people have just been through too much. I can't kick them out.
是的，我父亲不是那个意思，比如，那个孩子整晚吵得我睡不着。哦，感谢上帝，现在我可以睡觉了。他自己有孩子，所以他可能知道看着自己的孩子痛苦是什么感觉。所以对我父亲来说，那是一次非常情感上的羁绊，就像，这些人经历得太多了。我不能把他们赶出去。
In the end, he decided to sit down one more time and have a heart-to-heart talk with the couple. He told them he knew that they were good people. They just had a problem and they needed help. He would wait for the money they owed if the woman would just get help and go to rehab.
最终，他决定再坐下来进行一次交心谈话。他告诉他们他知道他们是好人。他们只是遇到了问题，需要帮助。如果那位女士愿意去康复中心接受治疗，他会等他们欠的钱。
If you do this, we'll repaint your apartment. Tell me what colors you want, and when you come back from rehab, we'll have this done for you. She wanted her kitchen painted yellow or something like that. And so she went to rehab. And I have a letter from her from August.
如果你这样做，我们就重新粉刷你们的公寓。告诉我你们想要什么颜色，等你从康复中心回来，我们会为你做好这一切。她想要她的厨房刷成黄色什么的。于是她去了康复中心。我还有一封她八月份写给我的信。
OK, why don't you read it?
好吧，你为什么不读一下？
Want me to read it? Sure. It says, well, I'm incarcerated and writing you from Cell Block C. You have no idea how touched I was by our talk, your caring, and generosity. The group here is very nice, as is the facility. I'm imagining what our apartment will look like upon my return. I'm so excited. I feel part of your family. You are in my prayers, which reminds me-- get your ass to church and make your ma happy.
想让我读？当然。上面写着，嗯，我被禁锢了，正在从C区写信给你。你不知道我们的谈话，你的关心和慷慨是多么触动我。这里的小组很好，设施也很好。我正在想象我回来时我们的公寓会是什么样子。我太兴奋了。我觉得自己是你们家庭的一部分。你一直在我的祷告中，这让我想起——快点去教堂，让你妈高兴点。
And when you got this letter, did you feel good?
当你收到这封信时，你感觉好吗？
Yeah, I felt really good. I was like, oh, this is great. She's in there, she's getting help. But then-- I don't know when it was-- a day or two or three later, I'm walking down the courtyard. And who do I see coming towards me but her. And this was supposed to be a two week or a month long stay. I was like, I can't believe it. Why is she-- and so that was the beginning of the end. Shortly after that is when I filed the court papers for eviction.
是的，我感觉很好。我想，噢，太棒了。她在那里，正在得到帮助。但后来——我不记得是什么时候了——一两天或三天后，我在庭院里走着。谁迎面朝我走来？竟然是她。这本来应该是两周或一个月的停留。我想，我简直不敢相信。她为什么会——那成了结局的开始。没多久我就提交了驱逐诉讼。
It was just-- it was devastating. It was like, ugh, you have to stand in front of the judge, looking at this person who I ran up and down the courtyard and maybe they threw the ball to me when I was, like, eight years old. And now I'm sitting here in front of the judge, telling them, Your Honor, please remove these people forcibly from the building. I'm like, that's what it comes down to. I have to do what I have to do to win this case. I was mad. I wanted them out.
这简直——太令人崩溃了。就像，呃，你必须站在法官面前，看着这个我曾经在庭院里跑来跑去，甚至可能在我8岁时还给我扔过球的人。现在我坐在这里在法官面前，告诉他们，法官大人，请强行把这些人从大楼里移走。我想，这就是结果。我必须做我必须做的事来赢得这场官司。我当时很生气。我想要他们出去。
And do you feel like this changed you?
你觉得这改变了你吗？
Definitely. Yeah, definitely changed me. Now, I don't like to get personally involved with tenants. Like, it's just too hard. One time, these two guys moved into a two-bedroom apartment. And they were like, aw, you guys are great. Why don't you come out and have a beer with us? I was like, you know what? I got something to do tonight. I'm sorry. Maybe some other time, though. I'd really love to get a beer with you.
肯定的。是的，肯定改变了我。现在，我不喜欢和住户有私交。这太难了。有一次，这两个人搬进了一个两居室。他们说，噢，你们真棒。为什么不出来跟我们喝杯啤酒呢？我说，你知道吗？我今晚有事。很抱歉。也许以后吧。我真的很想跟你们喝杯啤酒。
But I had no intentions of ever going out for a beer with them. I would just-- I don't know-- make up an excuse or avoid it at all costs because, you know, you can't be their friends. What I try and do now is I try to never have to kick somebody out. And the way I do that is by screening and screening and screening.
但我从没打算过真的去跟他们喝啤酒。我只是——我不知道——编个借口或不惜一切代价避免它，因为，你知道，你不能和他们做朋友。我现在尽量尝试的是，我尽量不去赶任何人走。我做到这一点的方法就是筛选、筛选、再筛选。
But that's the thing that I find interesting about this. I never thought about that as like it has anything to do with your feelings. This goes beyond the business stuff, that you're checking out all their credentials and all that sort of stuff. Are you saying it's actually like, it's too emotional?
但这就是我觉得这个故事有趣的地方。我从来没想过那与你的感受有关。这超越了生意，你检查他们所有的资历之类的东西。你是说这太情绪化了吗？
Yeah, it really is. I mean, for example, I do remember somebody coming in and applying for an apartment. And they're like, look, my credit's all messed up. I'm going through a divorce. And I don't know if my wife messed up my credit. And I was like, I don't care. Maybe that's the truth. Maybe that guy would have been a fine tenant. Maybe he would have paid his rent on time. But I just can't take that chance anymore.
是的，确实是。我的意思是，比如，我记得有人来申请公寓。他们说，看，我的信用全毁了。我正在离婚。我不知道是不是我妻子毁了我的信用。我说，我不在乎。也许那是真的。也许那个人会是一个很好的租户。也许他会按时交房租。但我不能再冒险了。
What would your Jesuit teacher say about that?
你的耶稣会老师会怎么评价这一点？
I don't know. Maybe they would be disappointed in it.
我不知道。也许他们会失望的。
And do you care?
你关心吗？
No. If they're mad about it, I would say, well, the next person who rented that apartment, Father, I did try to treat them justly and fairly and ethically.
不。如果他们对此生气，我会说，神父，租下那个公寓下一个人，我是尝试公正、公平且道德地对待他们的。
[MUSIC - "WORKING ON THE BUILDING" BY ELVIS PRESLEY]
[音乐 - 埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的“在建筑上工作”]
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Diane Cook, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show was Julie Snyder. Additional production on the rerun of today's show from Jessica Lussenhop, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Peter Roach, the super there that you heard at the very beginning of the show, he retired a few years ago. He now performs in, quote, "every nursing home in Northeast Pennsylvania under the name, 'The Singin' Super.'"
好吧，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己制作，还有黛安·库克、简·玛丽、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。今天节目重播的额外制作由杰西卡·卢森霍普、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼完成。彼得·罗奇，那个你在节目开头听到的管理员，他几年前退休了。他现在以“歌唱管理员”的名字在东北宾夕法尼亚州的每一家疗养院表演。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has this message for any This American Life employee who's listening to the radio right now.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交流）发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他给所有正在听收音机的《美国生活》员工带来了这个信息。
Don't try to steal one of the light bulbs in the hallway. I know what you're thinking, but I've booby trapped them.
别想偷走走廊里的灯泡。我知道你在想什么，但我已经设了陷阱。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。